oui plastic bertrand moi j'ai une
horrible chute attaque pendant
l'émission quoi il de quoi vous une
envie d'aller aux toilettes ça donne une
chute attaque en anglais et donc en fait
je me suis dit et en fait elle est
survenue à 20h48 au retour pur et
c'était un jeudi je me suis monté à une
demi heure l'émission se termine à 21h15
et j'avais oublié vous faisiez un prime
derrière je suis mort via la pub avant
le prime et à 21h12 audit à long manche
et tout de suite sans plus pendant deux
heures
j'étais mal et je voulais partir mais
c'est un débat très sérieux donc voilà
c'est pas vrai mais je n'arrivais plus à
marcher après c'est un drame non
vraiment les équipes s'en souviennent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]